[Music]
dianna fighting does not make you a
human what if I promise to be careful
just a shield and iron no sharp edges be
careful of mankind Diana
they do not deserve you you've told me
this story
[Music]
what is this place who are you people we
are the bridge to a greater
understanding right what is your mission
well here's the thing you are in more
danger than you think the boys in the
trenches called her doctor poison my
millions would die the war would never
end
I'm going mother if you choose to leave
you may never return how will I be a
Feist well technically the war is that
way but we got to go this way first how
can a woman fighting this who's this
young woman she's my
Diana Princess of Timnath Prince Diana
Prince
if you believe that this war should stop
help me stop it right now
what oh you will soon find out
Wonder Woman with a pg-13
hey youtubers it's raining trailers so
let's break down this new Wonder Woman
and we got to talk about some Justice
League I'm so happy about all this
footage this is the best trailer so far
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video I'll announce a new winner at
the end of this but they did this weird
thing where they open the trailer almost
like they cut it weird because of that
pop song we are the Warriors and they
reuse a shot from later in the trailer
so I don't know if this was an editing
error or they made to make it this way
but I think it's fine big confirmation
though before I go through this
shot-by-shot
is that they finally call out this
character is doctor poisoned the men in
the trenches call her doctor poisoned so
she's actually called dr. Moreau that's
her real name in the movie but the
doctor poison character in the comics
has always been a big Wonder Woman
villain now there's been a couple
different versions but the most modern
iteration is a younger character on par
with Wonder Woman's age but obviously
this is happening way back during World
War one so pretty much all these
characters regardless of what happens to
them in the movie would have died of old
age by now but they do this thing where
they opened the trailer with her
stepping out onto the battlefield
getting ready to be a fighter just as
her mother is telling her this bedtime
story saying that you don't have to be a
fighter to be a hero what is the
difference between what she was created
to be in what her mother wants her to be
so if it wasn't clear Wonder Woman was
born on that mascara the Amazons were
created before that mascara so Wonder
Woman comes after all this big Justice
League battle after all the craziness
they caused the need for temas Kyra just
like you're seeing in World War one here
Ares the God of War loves this he
thrives on war as they're saying during
the trailer they'll be war forever if
doctor poison is successful in
developing her new weapon but in ancient
times Ares caused all these problems so
Zeus created the Amazons to bring peace
Ares went against them started killing
the other gods Zeus was able to create
them Ischia and there's like a bubble
over it so you can tell why people
haven't found it before Steve Trevor
accidentally finds it but is part of the
mascara there's a lot of mystical things
going on they call it paradise but it is
very literally paradise because they are
immortal if you haven't read it there
was a free comic book day Wonder Woman
where they actually do a really good job
of explaining what it is to live on
temas Kira is one of the Amazons in a
really simple way so as long as they
live there and do not leave their
immortal they have paradise nobody can
touch them because it's hidden from the
rest of the world but because Steve
Trevor comes and tells them about this
poison while he's lassoed up I love the
fact that they lasso him when he's doing
this
Wonder Woman not having to live through
all the crap that was humanity a long
time ago like the other Amazons
is moved by the tragedy and says oh my
god I have to help everyone so when she
leaves she gives up her immortality but
she's part demigod so she does age at a
vastly slower rate than normal people
but had she stayed she would have lived
forever but like you see her during
Batman V Superman a hundred years later
she doesn't look like she's aged today
in this movie actually connects to
Justice League by jumping back and forth
in time you pick up with her looking at
all these old pictures remembering
things then you jump back to that
mascara the rest of the movie is set in
the past but a big part of her early
story in the movie like she talks here
is a little girl just a little bit can I
shoot can I have some fun is her trying
to train against her mother Hippolyta
swishes so she knows to Robin Wright
Penn and she trains her in secret till
they find out and they're like okay fine
you might as well go ahead and train
bright if you're gonna be doing it so
that's when you then get to sequences
like this with them all training in the
big circle that quote she has when she's
talking to Steve Trevor too is so
appropriate where the bridge to a
greater understanding so this movie is
also a bridge to a greater understanding
of the supernatural things in the DC EU
because that will be important when we
get to Justice League for Darkseid
minions so you learn about metahumans a
little bit during Batman V Superman now
you're learning more about the
supernatural side of things and there is
a Justice League dark movie that will
push way deeper into legit magic but
you'll learn a little bit about Chris
Pines character how he got a peek at all
this and then ran off with some of their
material and that's why the Austrians
are chasing him to Thema skier and you
have this big battle on the beach here
but as you can see Wonder Woman wants to
help the rest of the Amazons don't buy
his story so she looks like she's
climbing this special tower here I love
the way she just punches her way through
the stones he just makes her own
handholds that's one of those really
movie tricks just to have her do
something really practical like oh I
need to get up into this tower so she
climbs like it's no big deal but it lets
you know how powerful she can get
grabbing the lasso of truth grabbing the
shield grabbing her armor so you have
the god killer sword that's the really
important thing but everything else
these are all artifacts that were
created by the gods before Zeus died so
in the context of the movie when things
pick up these are like museum items that
haven't been used in a long long time
because they're all about hiding out on
Paradise Island there is no war here I
love her quote - right to war let's get
to it
nope no we got to go to the other way
first then you have the
fish-out-of-water comedy how do you
fight in this this is ridiculous
who is this young lady UC Aries again I
don't know what his human name is but
he's just a British lord we get a
slightly longer version of that scene
cut over this footage that we've seen
several times of her just jumping in and
taking out all these people in this room
simultaneously the real big thing here
though is her absorbing this energy
blast or at least deflecting it with her
gauntlets but no idea what kind of
energy is where it's coming from it's
got to have something to do with the
final boss fight with Ares just because
of the way everything looks crazy in the
background here there's that big
explosion later in the trailer we don't
know much about what the weapon does
it's just one of the makeup ins in the
film like that's the thing that helps
carry the story forward there's a weapon
they're developing we need to go stop
them or else war will cover the earth
but they are very careful not to
actually put a bowl on shot of Ares in
this and I think that's the smart thing
to do because we have a pretty good idea
what he looks like this is kind of a
sideways shot of him but even if you
haven't read a comic you have a pretty
good idea of what Ares might look like
you know the ease the big bill under the
film but there's gonna be so much stuff
that happens before you actually get to
him
this is one of my favorite shots here -
it's not even one of the action scenes
the action is great but I love the way
she just walks into a room like she just
owns the place you will find out very
soon who I am all this stuff from the
end of the trailer where she's running
around like she grabs this soldier while
she's running forward punching other
soldiers that's how strong she is is all
probably from that big final battle and
then this repeated shot of what looks
like her floating in the air I really
want to know whether or not she's gonna
fly in this movie because if she can do
it that's going to be bad
in really just like the last part here
just to show you what a badass she is
this armor here isn't glowing because
it's full of magic it's just full of
fire and energy like she's just soaking
all this damage like it's no big deal
but it was a great trailer I love the
energy I love the way it's setting up
some big concepts for Justice League as
well as like the physical way that it
sets it up jumping backwards and
forwards in time between Batman V
Superman and when that movie picks up
but there hasn't been any confirmation
other than a line of dialogue that isn't
in the trailer where Hippolyta says to
the other Amazons after Wonder Woman has
left maybe we should have told her the
big secret so there's some big secret
they don't reveal to Wonder Woman before
she leaves to go fight this war so that
could be a Justice League thing or that
could be an Ares thing and I think it's
more specific to Ares character just
telling them about the way he cloaks
himself in humanity because when she's
standing here talking to him it sounds
like she has absolutely no idea who he
is well let me know in the comments what
you guys favorite thing about the
trailer what do you most hype about for
the Wonder Woman movie I feel like the
energy is so much better than you saw in
the earlier trailers so people are just
getting more and more excited as we get
closer leave all your requests if
there's any comic book explainers or any
Justice League videos you guys want but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner hit man Quinn please private
message me so I can get your contact
details while you wait for my next video
click here for that spider-man
homecoming trailer and click here for
brand new clash thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight